the FDA has authorized the first blood
test for the corona virus it could
identify people who have been exposed to
the virus even those who did not show
any symptoms are dr. David agus joins us
from Los Angeles with more on this story
David so what is this blood test detect
and how is it different from the
available tests that we have on the
market now so the current tests look if
you have the virus they look for the RNA
of the virus and they say whether it's
there this looks at immunity so by
taking a drop of blood they can actually
know whether you've been exposed to the
virus symptomatic or asymptomatic which
is critical because it means that you
can no longer get the virus at least in
the short term you know in countries
like England and Germany they're talking
about giving out immunity certificates
because those people can actually leave
their home and maybe get their economy
started so how will people get the
chests of David because we keep hearing
you're a big risk for infection by going
to a medical facility you hit the key
question so this is a test that will
initially be at medical facilities
because you have to draw blood the White
House has said repeatedly that their
hope is that could be a finger prick
where in the future you could just put a
dot of your blood on a piece of paper
and mail that in and have a result right
away and so it takes about 15 minutes to
run this test so the hope is we're gonna
transition to doing this in other places
other than the medical system but right
now it's confined to the doctor's office
pretty soon every time you go to the
doctor's office they'll check to see if
you have immunity or not and you think
this test is important in fighting the
virus why well I think it's critical I
mean we have to say who's been exposed
and not because they'll be treated
differently in that they can actually be
on our front line they can't get
affected again so they could be our
ambulance drivers are people working in
the emergency room are people working at
cash registers and at the same time we
can use it to develop vaccines this is
the same test to say are vaccines
working are we giving immunity by giving
someone a vaccine to this deadly virus
David can we please talk about the mass
situation I think it is so confusing
in the beginning we were told you know
you don't really need to wear a mask if
you're a healthy
and walking around but a person who's
infected should the White House is now
signaling that they're going to
encourage all of us to wear a mask or
some kind of face covering in Los
Angeles in the city of New York they're
already telling us that we should why is
this changing now
well it's our understanding of the virus
is that when you're asymptomatic or
pre-symptomatic you can spread the virus
so the days before you get symptoms you
can spread the virus and also people
never have symptoms those people from
the droplets in their mouth when they
breathe or cough can spread the virus so
the man the man dating of the mask I
think makes total sense across the
country and what it does is it protects
other people so you won't spread the
virus even if you don't know you have it
so all of us should wear covering when
we go out it could be a bandana doesn't
have to be an n95 mask and it shouldn't
be it should just be a covering
yeah please let people know that people
were wearing bandanas are not up to no
good now it really is a safety issue
because when I heard yesterday for the
first time that now you can get it it
can be spread by talking or breathing I
went hah the corona virus seems to be
such a moving target with the rules
always seeming to change yeah I mean
we're learning as we go because this is
a totally new virus but when you breathe
on a mirror those droplets I mean that's
what they are the fog on the mirror you
have to block them and so wearing
something when you go out is a sign of
respect for others and I think
critically important in stopping the
virus all right dr. agus thank you very
much